a populist Tsar coming to power and
increasing divisive and polarized
society that is the new divide that is
the new debate I think the reason we're
having this debate is that something
quite fundamental is happening there is
a fundamental disruption in Western
foreign policy which is deeply troubling
and deeply worrying and one of the ways
that you can see how much the world is
changing and how quick the chaos which
Donald Trump has unleashed is going
through our our political systems our
international institutions is the fact
that even Donald Trump jokes getting out
of date very quickly during the election
campaign in Conan O'Brien quipped the
70% of Americans were deeply worried
about the idea of a trump presidency and
30% were becoming Canadian but if he was
making the joke now he'd realized that
the last thing anyone want to do is to
become Canadian because Donald Trump
seems to have a particular animus
against America's northern neighbor and
sees it as one of the the worst
foes of the American system and I think
the reason for that is that he has a
fundamentally different worldview from
President Obama President Bush Bush the
father Clinton Reagan or any of the
other presidents that have been in power
at least in the last hundred years and I
think there's three things which are
uniquely worrying about Trump as
president the first is that he is the
only u.s. president in my lifetime who
has seen the international order as
something which undermines rather than
enhances American power in the world and
I don't think that he thinks that that
order doesn't benefit the West and
benefit the US but he does think that it
benefits others more in particular China
and his starting point is that if he
doesn't
nothing at all he will be the president
that oversees the relative decline of
his great nation and that China will
become the most powerful country in the
world because every year China becomes
stronger and richer and the u.s. in
relative terms even though it grows is
it's becoming smaller and he but he
thinks that the entire establishment and
the elite is so wedded to this order in
this way of doing things that it's
incapable of reforming it and therefore
what I think he's trying to do is to
launch a process of Schumpeterian
creative destruction we're the first
instance is to blow everything up with a
view then to renegotiating the order on
terms which he thinks are more
beneficial to the US because he thinks
the paradox of the status quo is that
America is paying a lot of money is
losing a lot of lives in order to
sustain an order which is helping China
more than America and that's why he's
blown up the jcpoa the Iran nuclear deal
which George was talking about why he
was trying to blow up the World Trade
Organization why he's threatening NATO
why he's withdrawing from almost
everybody that you can think of in the
United Nations um it's because these are
part of an order which he thinks the
u.s. is trapped in which constrains it
and above all in his very zero-sum mind
these are all institutions which empower
the week over the strong and America is
the strongest than the most powerful
country in the world
so therefore any institution which
brings countries together to negotiate
with the u.s. is one which in relative
terms weakens the US and strengthens
other countries against it and that
brings me to the second threat of Donald
Trump as president which is the fact
that going back to my Canadian example
the people that he feels the greatest
animus to our American allies because
they're the ones who are propping up the
system the most so he thinks that they
are the number one enemies in his
process of disrupting the global order
that's why he's much more comfortable
dealing with Vladimir Putin or Kim
jong-un than dealing with Angela Merkel
and the fact that he's undermining u.s.
alliances means for every single part of
the world where order has been based on
alliances with the United
is becoming much more unsafe that's true
of Europe it's true of Asia it's true
for Middle East and what's happening is
two things are going on as American
alliances become questioned and people
don't know whether they can count on
normal Trump to back them up the
American allies are having to hedge
against being abandoned by the United
States so they're having to rethink
their options to rearm and to up their
military spending at the same time the
enemies of the United States its rivals
also wondering whether the u.s. is going
to back up their allies so they're
testing out how far America will stand
by its allies and they're also
encouraged to rearm and to behave in
belligerent ways so in every theater of
the world what we're going to see over
the next few years and new levels of
instability new levels of violence and
the the problems which George Galloway
was talking about in the Middle East and
not about Western foreign policy and us
arming relatively dysfunctional groups
in Syria it's about the fact that there
was an order which was guaranteed by
Western powers which has now disappeared
and that's created a space where Iran
and Saudi Arabia and others who were
held together in place by a system and
now testing out their power and fighting
death and nobody cares about what
they're doing and no one's trying to
stop them and there are no limits on the
instability which can happen as a result
of that
well as half an Irishman I'm entitled to
say as the Irishman apocryphally did
when asked the road to London I wouldn't
have started from here the exceptional
ization of Donald Trump to which you've
just been listening is absurd Donald
Trump's been the president of the United
States for less than two years did the
chaos in the world start less than two
years ago it's utterly ridiculous the
crooner your idol
nice suit Barack destroyed Libya and
turned it into a slave market and a
jihad market for at least seven heavily
armed different Islamist groups wasn't
Trump that did that was Obama that did
that you have the goal to pray and eat
George W Bush is somehow better than
Donald Trump George W Bush and your
other hero Tony Blair killed a million
people in Iraq and rising spawned Isis
cascaded across the world you see how
happy how smug you are about the
rules-based society that we had before
Donald Trump 23 months ago 22 months ago
where was the rules-based order in the
invasion and occupation of Iraq and in
age of your argument you draw attention
to the fact that populist SAR coming to
power the populist SAR coming to power
precisely because of the failure of your
international order precisely because of
the failure of your orthodoxy it's
because neoliberal politics totally
failed in Italy that you have the
government in Italy you have d2 in
Hungary get all the rise
though it stopped now you may have
noticed that melon song with whom I
agree in every particular is now the
most popular politician in France not
lepen she's gone off for psychiatric
treatment the the rise of Trump the rise
of carbon the rise of the right and the
populace in Italy are all because of the
failure of this order which you so
smugly wish to return us to so let me
give you three things that I think
really make up the combination of things
that makes China right now distinctive
and which then help us decide whether or
not those are things that are going to
challenge I don't the West I mean the
liberal world I think is what we're
talking about here but let's call it the
West in the next few years and decades
and those three things are authoritarian
politics economic growth and directed
use of highly sophisticated technology I
think those are the three things which I
think come together to become much more
than certainly the sum of their parts so
number one is authoritarian politics
China is one of a very small number of
countries that is not only not Liberal
Democratic but also doesn't make any
pretense at being so Russia is different
Russia holds elections I am told by
various people that those elections are
not always entirely free and fair
sometimes those people then turn up
deceased in a in a gutter somewhere in
in Moscow but in a sense that happening
is a sort of hypocritical nod of the hat
to the idea that there ought to be
elections there ought to be liberal
politics even if they don't really work
at all in some of that Russia this is
not what China is saying this is not
what President Xi Jinping is saying he
has made it very clear that the Leninist
style of government in which an
authoritarian as they would see it
meritocratic top-down system through one
party operates is appropriate to the
need of China and also in many ways
superior in terms of the governance it
could put forward while
the judgments there are certain recent
Democratic decisions in certain Western
countries that at least in the minds of
some Chinese elites have confirmed them
in that view second point is about
economic growth don't tread on Linda's
very shiny wave in this extremely
competent economic toes when very very
fine tears they are here but the fact is
that many of the things were friendly
about you thought you were here to talk
about the future fear politics instead
we're getting to all sorts of very very
devious stuff the direction of travel
has been clear for some time but some of
you may have noticed a phrase which has
not become very kind of common currency
in the China discussion world from the
former paramount leader Deng Xiaoping
who was you know essentially in charge
through the 1980s and much of the 1990s
and he put forward what's become known
as the sixteen character phrase in
Chinese that's how Guang young-hui which
is basically about look keep your head
down China make money get your education
system together start your economic
growth going leave it a good long while
ten years 20 years 25 years 30 years
then bring your light from under that
bushel and shine Xi Jinping the leader
we have now in China is the one who's
basically taking advantage of that
economic growth that done shopping was
putting forward as the plan for not just
a year or two but for decades and saying
that now we reap the benefits of that
and the third point and I'm looking here
at our chair who despite her kind of
fact I put it the discrete statements as
in fact one of the great experts the UK
has on technology may have seen her on
TVs panorama recently not the one about
abuse in care homes that was definitely
not Stephanie technological there
wouldn't say what role you were playing
in that one but the one about technology
West definitely has a great deal to say
about the way in which liberal and non
liberal societies are changing because
of the technology but on the case of
China I will say that the ability to
produce maybe not first tier innovation
but extremely high qualities second tier
innovation in artificial intelligence
virtual reality telecommunications why
are we having the organs were having in
the UK about whether we should have a
highway network because Huawei whatever
else you think about the politics is
perhaps the single best quality and best
value telecommunications infrastructure
that you can get the fact that China can
go from 40 years ago being basically one
of the poorest countries per world in
the world per capita to being a country
that can seriously consider itself a
cybernetic superpower is amazing and the
consequences of that in China of course
are that the state now uses that power
to surveil its own citizens in a non
liberal society without the benefit of
independent oversight from the courts
without elections that can change the
government that level of technological
power with that level of economic growth
and authoritarian politics is a
never-before-seen combination that is
what the West needs to engage with
understand and debate what is happening
in the West from America through
throughout sort of Western and Eastern
Europe it's it's a fragmentation and a
breakdown and the successful parties are
no longer to be understood on the
left-right spectrum they're actually a
mixture of left and right there are
socialists who believe in leave there
are socialists who believe in remain but
leave and remain are now better
predictors of who you're going to vote
for than your past tribal identity so
what's really happening is is
realignment and fragmentation and
largely speaking I want to suggest to
you that the formulation that's taking
place and I think you know you you got
it in one is nationalism on the one hand
an extreme liberalism understood as
identity politics on the other and I
won't suggest you that neither of them
ultimately in my view will work because
we have been governed by extreme
liberalism for really since since the
time of Margaret Thatcher you have
extreme economic liberalism on the right
extreme social liberalism on the left
and there a common project and I always
think it's incoherent to hear people on
the left's denouncing neoliberalism
economically but essentially upholding
its social
and vice-versa so what is the liberal
project that is now over
the liberal project is essentially a
grand global project of extreme
individualism and this grand global
project have first appealed to the
narcissism of the 1960s and the genuine
injustice --is that the 1960s spoke to
but what it creates is a dispensation
economically that only favors those at
the very very top if you look at the
global distribution the famous elephant
graph by Branko Milanovic he shows that
really over the last 3040 years has been
no net gain for the vast majority of the
working population from globalization
and the gain has been for the working
class in the third world whereas the
working class and increasing the middle
class in the first world has seen no
genuine gain at all you've seen the rise
of rampant insecurity because insecurity
stems from Brampton to individualism and
we've created on the economic level
forms of insecurity that we're actually
unthinkable in the 60s or indeed the 70s
but on the cultural right and culture we
know outcompetes economics in any
assessment of human behavior liberalism
has essentially created a culture that
oppresses majorities that creates
marginalized majorities through identity
politics that are little more than
middle class power games and attempts by
middle class advocates to both virtue
signal and gain power within a medium
whereby solidarity has collapsed so
don't be surprised that nationalism is
on the way back because nationalism by
those who advocate for it is the only
thing that will care for them
nationalism by it
from the perspective it's of advocates
is the only thing that will care for
those who have lost out whereas
liberalism won't liberalism of of the
extreme left has become an upper-middle
class project and so what we've got is a
project where so
garetty are looking after us all has
been captured by nationalism and the
project the right-wing project of
extreme individualism is now followed by
both left-wing parties and right-wing
parties that is the new divide that is
the new debate that is where we are so
there are we can begin with the fact
that many of us intuitively implicitly
feel that there is a lacking center in
politics and that there is an increasing
divisive and polarized societies so John
Curtis for example the polar polling
guru from stirling argues that british
opinion used to be a bell curve with the
votes in the center and it's now a
u-shape with the votes on either side
and nothing left in the center there are
two responses to this one of them is
that this is almost an inevitable
feature of the nature of modern
discourse partly fueled by social media
in other words really this phone in my
pocket and the things that it enables
encourages the creation of a public that
comes together very quickly against
something that a line runs from the arab
spring through to brexit and part of
that line is the general story that
there is to quote my friend david who's
just accused me of living in a bubble
that there is these people living in a
bubble being a right-wing populist
people living in a bubble
okay and it's the classic language from
that thing right you guys live in a
bubble and the story is that there are a
bunch of people who are out of touch
living up on the top of a little pyramid
who don't really understand what's going
on on the ground and this becomes a very
powerful weapon doesn't matter whether
you're in Egypt or in Britain for
chucking a hand grenade at those people
it tends to be a negative program it's
very difficult to translate this
movement whether you're talking about
the Arab Spring or breaks it into a
positive program of government because
it tends to be an objection towards a
particular group of people now the
then is how inevitable is this is there
something about the modern world
something about this machine which means
that any attempt to create a center
ground is doomed and in fact actually
the professor suggested that it is in
the very nature of democratic politics
that an attempt to define a center
ground and consensus is anti-democratic
implication and her agonistic vision is
that actually a truly liberal democracy
involves different positions people
dividing lines between them she likes
the divide between left and right she
doesn't like any other divides but she
basically believes democracy involves
standoffs between one group and another
I think it is possible though to
conceive of something more than simply
what she was suggesting so she was
suggesting that the resolution to this
is to think of a more dignified
courteous way of imagining that
disagreement between the two sides the
two sides continue but that there are
rules by which they play and they give
respect to each other's positions I
would argue that there is a way of being
a trumpian anti-trump that there is a
way of using this machine to advocate
not for the positions of the right or
the left not for the positions of no do
brexit or remain not for the positions
of equality against liberty that there
is a way of using this to connect to the
local and the more things are embedded
in the locals and more plausible it is
that through practical work through
action you can discover the virtue of
moderation right the virtue of avoiding
the extremes the energy that comes from
the intermediate state and I want to
conclude on this Heraclitus since we're
talking about philosophy is very
interesting the idea of harmony and what
Heraclitus points out is that harmony
comes not by losing the opposites but by
suspending the power of the opposites he
talks about harmony in relation to a
musical instrument the sound of the
string comes from the string being
suspended through the tension of the bow
I'm even more interested in harmony
through the bow itself the sense that
the center ground in fact is pulling off
those two ends drawing the patriotism
from one the sense of liberty of the
other and then the sense of compassion
or social justice the other in order to
create that form and what gives it its
force is that it operates in the realm
of reality thank you for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the institute of arts and ideas at iai
TV
you